smoked haddock and spinach bait eggs
smoked haddock one of my favorite fish
delicious highly sustainable it's packed
with protein lightly smoked there's not
a die smoked there's big difference you
have got that bright yellow tinge so
much better next baby spinach is this
finish that's very young for the zinc
great flavor your teaspoon volleyball
knob of butter that little touch of oil
stops the butter from burning it looks
like a lot of spinach but it's going to
disintegrate forward by two-thirds when
I'm cooking spinach in butter I've been
at the top of my pepper mill so the
pepper becomes almost like so cracked
pepper lots of fine once your spinach
has reduced down by two-thirds
adding your cubes of smoked haddock
tarragon it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart pick off the little
buds from the stalks keep all of these
and grateful when you're making a
tarragon vinegar red wine vinegar
tarragon stalks in chopped the tarragon
into your creme fraiche little season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with had a incredible this mustardy
herby creme fraiche will work equally
well partnered with grilled chicken the
haddock starting to slake because it's
smoked lightly cured it cooks so quickly
your creme fraiche
now some once at the beginning of the
perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are gonna
bake on top seal is wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off now crack your eggs
around the outside just a little twist
the pepper get the remainder of your
creme freshen and little dollop in
between that adds richness to the egg
whites into the oven at 180 for 10 to 12
minutes
what's the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
and garnish professional kitchen chefs
refuse to use the top of the spring
onions but I love that nice dark green
flavor it's less harsh and the white the
smell of baked mustard you can't beat
that is beautiful
spinach was almost melted in with a hat
up now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
Wow
my ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron
you'll be raring to dive into the day
ahead
you